请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
好同學們歡迎來喔
這個有沒有
沒有聽到我聲音的
有聽到嗎
好太好了喔
我們這第一次就成功了
這背景音樂會不會太吵
沒有還好喔
好稍等我一下
五分鐘 等我一下
看到非常多熟面孔
非常多熟面孔
今天
今天人應該不多啦
今天人不會多的
因為大家知道嗎
每次大碟都是這個狀況
但是我們還是要繼續做
因為還是有同學會希望來聊東西
這是我是知道的
一片小粉
2片
3片
4片
1片
2片
4片好等我一下下
我们五分钟
留五分钟就好了
大家上礼拜还好吗
同学们上礼拜还好吗
上禮拜有没有
同学非常的
惨烈的
有没有
我们这个地方就是一个
有温暖的地方
老实讲
就是我们进来投资
哪有
哪有不挨刀的
那重点就是你必须要
用一个什么样的心态
这个是我觉得
今天比较重要的东西
一個利空這樣打過來
你要用什麼樣的心態去面對
這個我覺得也是
大家會需要
培養的一個技能
因為不可能是
投資不可能就是
每天漲漲漲漲
對吧
這部分沒有問題
大家就
邊聽歌邊聽我講廢話
好不好
好
我們今天就算來聊天來聊天這樣子大家不用覺得說
我們好像一定要在
一定要在股市裡面必勝
其實是這樣
很多同學都有一個
不要說壞習慣
新手都會有一個
我不希望去講一些什麼
這是大家
你的問題還是什麼
沒有
就是會有一個盲點
就是你會一直在股市裡面去找到
所謂的聖杯
就是一個必勝的策略
穩賺不賠的東西
但是這部分不太可能
不太可能
但是我們只能去尋找什麼
就是相對勝率比較高的東西
我觉得其实
我们前阵子
大家一窝蜂
其实都在focus在同样一块
哪一块就是
找好的标的
找喷出去的标的
但是我们其实
股票里面真的有讲到一个部分
就是选股
然后进场出场
第三个就是什么
心态
心态这些东西
我们之前和大家讲
這個心態這些東西
可能比較
比較少人會去去注意
為什麼因為
盤施好嗎
那你不要跟我講廢話
我們就是
這個直接開始
對不對
其實我覺得現在大家
今天現在這個狀況
我們就當聽Podcast就好了
當聽Podcast為什麼
因為
現在這樣一根下來
就是沒有人是
這個
玩
就是毫法无伤的
毫法无伤的
重点是你必须要有一个出口
心态要有一个出口
那我们这个地方
今天就上来和大家聊聊这个部分
聊聊这个部分
音乐不会太大声吧
我觉得蛮适合今天聊天的
的一个背景
当然我们今天不只会讲这个部分
还是有帮大家准备一下
我们之前讲的一些策略选顾清单
這個部分
今天就比較不會去
有什麼課綱那個部分
但是
我還是有一些筆記還是有筆記這些我還是有稍微准备给大家操作回顾然后策略选拂不是清单清单
清单
然后我们公开群的
这些投票的
然后还有
这个订阅的
一定会带到的
当然我们
昨天其实已经有带过一轮
但是就是
今天再一次
再一次
可能昨天有漏掉一些的
我們今天再來講一次
再來講一次
OK
好
那其實
對我看到很多同學
我們盡量在聊天室
可以做個聊天互動這樣
畢竟可能還有同學
還沒有進來
我們今天輕鬆一點
因為我知道大家非常緊張
這個部分我們等一下都會交代
都會交代規劃這樣
因為
我們不是說
我是在這個
這個
盒子之外
懂你什麼
同學
我也是局内人
所以我会分享一下
我们到底要怎么样去看待这个部分
大家了解我意思吗
因为我为什么说是局内人局外人
因为其实很多的地方
他是其实没有
对盘面是没有感受的
他就是在外面这样子
就是讲一讲这样
但其实他很多人都已经没有在
实际在操作了
但是我们不行
还是在这个市场里面打滚
所以同学
我们是同一个阵线的
同一个阵线的
所以
这个怎么样去规划
也是我自己要去
和大家去做分享
这样子
那就是
你听听看
你就听听看就好了
听听看
不用当作是
这个是一个老师讲的东西
他讲的东西一定对
同學沒有
大家知道我們
我和主角大和大家的教學上面
都是互動
互動
然後
持續去做
学習
因為
這次場上面要學東西
實在是太多了
真的太多了
OK
好
我們來看一下
大家
哪些同學已經進來
今天還是有100多位同學
歡迎你們
真的歡迎你們
我們就稍微聊聊
這樣子
OK
好
這背景音樂應該不會影響到我們
大家聽的部分嘛
對不對
聽的部分應該不會
如果你覺得很吵還是已經影響到我
我聽主義大講話的東西的話
你跟我講一下
因為我們這已經是放到最小聲最小聲的部分
好
齊維你好
哇這些都是鐵粉進來
歡迎大家
歡迎你們
Lian 邵峰 Hello
Kenny Hello
好待會要邊開車邊聽直播了
好感動
那沒關係你就當聽Podcast就可以了
發開手 OK好再來
騎豪我應該沒念錯
清號嗎OK你好
好 蘇婆蘇婆
蘇婆OK哈囉哈囉
這也是非常厲害的一位戰友
這些這幾位都非常的
的厲害
已經
已經做的爐火純青了不要說爐火純青了就是至少
知道自己在幹嘛
好知道是自己在幹嘛
同学们在操作
你只要有私讯给我
或者是你有在
这个我们看一下
有在我的文章下面
文章下面
发文的
像你只要在这种文章下面
文章底下下面
这边有发文的
其实我都会去记你的名字
都会去记你的名字
OK
已经认识蛮多同学了
好
晚宏
应该是圆红
你好
我是主力大粉丝
你特别把这个名字改成
你不让我注意真的很难
欢迎你
真的谢谢你
看起来真的是粉丝
160位
等下我们一样稍微
今天就是同学记得
我们今天就是轻松一点
因为我知道
大家的心情已经够紧张了
明天已经够紧张
但是
轻松归轻松
我们该讲的还是要讲给大家
好
如如你好
正宇你好
德宗晚上好
Jerry hello
滾滾
滾滾來了
這是超級厲害的
超級厲害的
這個短打
然後絕對不會傷到自己
已經開始
把我
把我的
我把我的名言已經
都學進去了
就是絕對不會讓自己被傷到
這是非常厲害
這個
Lin Starless
Starless Starless也是一位非常厲害的朋友戰友真的是這個對浪單也是非常的厲害對浪非常厲害就差小編一點點而已
差小編一點點沒關係
小編都偏向做波段
反正我就會跟他
就是下一些指導期
當然他盈虧當然自負
反正就是
好他自己自己操作
自己操作 ok
好再来
圆圆你好
子凌哈喽 Sam
好再来
及时好
App及时你好
裴琪叶晨哈喽大家好
好差不多了
都应该都没有问题
好来同学同学来同学来
开始要问一下
好点点名你没问题
来这个Chain
Lena
点名你
没问题
OK
很好听的背景音乐
好
谢谢你
诶
健旗
好朋友
这是现实中的好朋友
健旗
好
就反正
今天
我们就放轻松
来
好
同学们应该没有太大问题
我们就开始
来
我先问一个问题就好了
我们在开始之前
我就先问一个问题
我们就了解一下
大家在这个地方
看到有新同学加入
这个言心
你好
上礼拜
你看到我们上礼拜讲的
直播
有提醒大家一件事情
提醒大家一件事情
就是还记不记得我们上礼拜的PPT
我把它叫出来一下
让大家比较有一点
印象
大家应该知道我想讲什么
我们上礼拜的规划
我蛮喜欢去看我们之前做的规划
然后看你有没有真的去按表操课
等一下
来
来这是我们上礼拜的
上礼拜的规划
来看到一个部分
这个大方向结论
这个五日线是绝对不能破的
那你如果
我问一下上礼拜你破五日线的时候
你有去谨慎
不要说减码
你一破五日线之后
之后
這個地方破五日線之後
你有去稍微的
這個做一些動作的可能你是這個停損或停力的就是你開始解碼你的部位有看到我們之前上禮拜講因為我就是當這個地方的同學是完全都沒有訂閱的
你就是每個禮拜來聽直播的
來聽直播
來聽我們怎麼樣做規劃的
我們上禮拜講的
拉上來到這個位置
很明確的
就是跟大家講
你的資金水位反而要變成
降到四成以內
因为我知道很多地方反而会跟你说
从这边五六七八
有一定到八成了
放到八成了
但是我很明确的
跟大家讲到一个部分就是
到这个地方你反而变成多少
变成四成
为什么
钱高尊重
尊重钱高
那我们就是把这个
每次的直播当成是
每个同学都没有订阅
我们就是只追踪我们之前讲的部分就好了
ok 因为我不喜欢就是
让大家觉得好像
我们就是一直讲这个
订阅的同学才看得到的内容
这样子 ok
所以就是你发现
我们上礼拜有讲到
你跌破五日线
你要开始小心这个部分
你有去找盘
有开始去做减码的
你帮我回应一下
让我知道
你上礼拜你做了哪一些的处理
在这一根
在这一根下来之前
你有把我讲的东西听进去
稍微的反而是去
别人再开始增加持股
然后增加它的部位的时候
你有把我东西讲的听进去
你跟我讲一下
然后这边Starlers说只有三成
只剩三成
没错
就差不多嘛
差不多
因为我们很
大家其实可以学到一个
就是一个叫做FOMO
FOMO
什么意思就是
很担心
没有去
被尬控手
对不对
但是如果我们用这个
这个观念
你至少留个三四成
其实你在这个地方
它突破了
你还是有
但是如果现在跌破跌下去
你还是不会有太大的伤害
了解我意思吗
所以
其实这个地方
我们在上礼拜
对对对
我们其实
上礼拜
在星期四星期五的時候我們可以看一下
現在就開始了
我們先看一下上禮拜上禮拜上禮拜我們所講的部分這個地方星期五
然後星期四
看一下這個地方
來
其實從星期四的地方
星期四的時候
這是我們的訂閱的群組
從星期四的時候
我們就開始請大家要小心
這是星期四的盤錢
盤錢都會寫
寫一個部分
給大家去follow一下參考
我們今天的操作的策略這樣子
好 星期四是這一天嘛
這一天 好 這一天 好
特別請大家留意一件事情
好 23號剉下來
23號剉下來
那你隔一天
隔一天這個地方一定會有一個多方的力道
好 這是我們星期二和三的完全不同的操作態度
星期三其實到這個十字線附近
又到这个前面
这个
17650的位置
其实会有一个
短线的支撑
所以你会发现
24号
24号这一天
其实是好做的
24号星期三这一天
OK
好
但是
如果我们要继续要
让大家去
小心这个部分的话
好
那就是
在这一天
星期四
昨天
带量收红的标的
你要非常小心一件事情
今天开低的话
他只要今天是开低
你就要真的非常留意了
非常小心
所以
其实订阅同学应该都知道
我们开盘的时候
开盘的时候
不会去追股票了
这个地方
开盘
我第一件事情
来同学
你应该知道
我要讲什么
开盘第一件事情
是要做什么事情
同学来
你已经学了这么久
对不对
这节奏学了这么久
我们开盘第一件事情
不会是去买进
不会去做买进
这个是现在跌破五日线
后面的一个节奏
开盘反而是要怎么样
去顾什么
顾你的持股
绝对是这样
因为非常多的情况
非常多的情况怎么样
就是开盘拉上去之后
开盘拉上去之后
好
對沒錯看到很多同學已經開始在回覆了
這個都好習慣學起來了
好習慣學起來了
至少你要和整個市場做到一個差別性
你開盤拉上去
非常容易怎麼樣
一根黑K直接灌下來
我這邊說的是什麼
說的是5分K
5分K
我現在這個滑鼠不太好用
手還在復健當中
5分K
你碰到這種情況了
你已經放棄了
你已經放棄了開盤這15分鐘
可能10分鐘15分鐘去
这个做短冲的机会了
那你就要把你该赚的
该停利该停顺的
或者有些败向出来的
你该去处理掉
懂意思吗
这是你应得的
你放弃你开盘的去追高的
这些短冲的机会
那你就要把这个时间
去做更好的应用
懂意思吗
什么意思
很简单
开盘非常多情况是这样子
然后拉上去
但是呢
你会发现
第三根还是第几根
马上一根5分可以灌下来
这种
就是他今天不会太好
不会太好
长红两根拉上去
结果一根可以灌下来
这种的话
就是我早盘开始要去处理的对象
这是第一种状况
第二种就是直接
昨天是收什么
收十红
然后隔天开一个低
开地开这个位置
这也是我会
开盘就会去处理
去减码的
减码的
这感觉好像在骂人
没有没有没有
去降低
就是卖出的
的情况
了解我意思吗
这样子是什么
这样子是五分K
找盘急拉拉上去
来这一天会这样
同学
这一天是这个状况
懂吗
然后这一天也是
这一天也是
这三天
这三天全部都是
我刚刚讲这种状况
就是非常容易拉上去
然后拉上去
然后结果
10分15分之后
一根又灌下来
你可以去找
你可以回顾一下
现在可能
大部分标定
你去回
回看他的
这个星期四
还有星期五
他的K棒
K棒
5分K的K棒
都是拉上去之后
往下灌
那個時候就是我要去減碼的時候了了解意思嗎對我看到很多同学已经有在回复回复我们这个操作的节奏
好这是星期四
第一天有这个状况
让你小心去做减码
好第二个
直接来看星期五
好来
这边讲了更明确一个问题
更明确一点
更明确的一点
这边看了一下
雅谷普遍弱势
然后期货直接跳空跌到景线的位置
今日外资还是放假
放两天嘛
这边我们已经有
星期四已经和大家讲了
基本上也是没有什么买盘
跟昨天格局会很类似
你的成本很高的个股
什么意思
你的成本是你昨天
昨天那根红K
前天那根红K进去的
你短线上面还没有拉个10%以上
都算是成本高的
早盘有机会
同学
在26号这一天
你早盘是有一个机会
拉高可以去占什么
占卖方的
相信我
因为
星期五的早盘
是绝对有让大家
离开
或者是减码的机会
相信我
为什么
因为你尾盘
尾盘不会有人拉
原因都已经写在一开始
前面了
因为外资是在放假
就这样
所以尾盘
不会有人来拉
又是星期五
然后大家就会很紧张
很紧张就怎么样
很紧张下个动作
就是
卖股票
对不对
好
对这边STARLESS
有说到一个很重点
其实我这边讲到
今天期货蛮有趣的
什么意思
就星期五
期貨居然開跌停
期貨開跌停
這個就是標準的
沒有外資進來
然後是內資自己在那邊亂戳
懂意思嗎
但是開跌停
付好像1600多點吧
就是開一個跌停這樣
其實你對於今天的股市操作
你其實就要有一點點的什麼
有一點警覺了
對所以
沒錯沒錯
這邊有人可以幫我們作證
你只要找盘
找盘
它其实没有到很狠
懂意思吗
阻力没有到很狠
它找盘都还是有让你拉高一次上去但是就是懂吗那就是五分钟十分钟就是我刚刚讲的就是两根
五分十分
然后面刷下去
就是这样
所以你绝对有机会去
怎么样
占卖方
早盘有机会会往上拉高
但是你要去占什么
占卖方而不是占买方
OK这边都有提醒到
OK
好
那你说
总的来说
这前面
我们都已经有规划进去
但重点是
你现在一定是要问
那明天该怎么样做
对不对
我可能
星期五的时候
星期四
我可能这节奏没有跟上
我相信大家应该
还是有同学会care这个重点
好
那我们现在就来讲下一个部分了
同学你听到目前
你觉得
没有什么太大问题
就帮我打加一就好了
我喝一口水
今天蛮神奇的
结果还是有200多位同学
等一下我们会分享
QA的部分
还有策略选顾清单
然后再来
因为就没了
我们今天就是闲聊
然后讲一些
要分享的东西
这样子
OK
好 真的
希望我們在這個前面做的一些規劃
還有盤前的一些
讓大家的操作提醒
有幫助到大家
就這樣
那你說 主題大你這樣子
這麼
講了這樣子
就幫大家做著
你自己怎么办
我其实同学
我只有一个重点就是
进来操作
没有不受伤的
懂吗
我还是有套劳在那边的
懂意思吗
但重点是
你买进去你的部位
你不要大嘛
对不对
然后你找盘拉高出去
出一趟
你至少你会把你的
我一定会把我的
这个部位放到
就是安心
没关系你就往下跌
我也不怕的那一种
水位
懂意思嗎
怎麼可能這樣出一個病毒他有種就直接往一萬去灌怎麼可能對不對好好來看一下來星期一非常重要一點
我們來聽一下
好
第一個位置
第二個位置這個圖
銅鬚應該看過了
我這邊畫一下
這個頸線先切一下
切過來你也可以畫
你也會畫
你把最多
最多
跟大家講
你把最多K棒
就是
轉折的地方
這個切過來
切過去
這個畢松同學說
星期一解割盤
我現在就在做這件事情
你不要急
今天就輕鬆一點
我该讲还是会讲
好吗
你很急的话
你听完就可以走了
OK
好
这边紧线切过来
然后
季线叫出来
布林轨道叫出来
好
看一下
这个位置其实
这个非常多支撑
非常多支撑
第一个是什么
第一个是紧线
紧线差不多在17100的位置
然后
季线在17168的位置
然后下轨这个位置
下轨
你看通道底这个地方
不是通道底
就是这个通道的底部
它明天会上来
明天会上来一点
所以也差不多
也差不多就是在17100
这个位置
懂意思吗
我是讲非常简单而暴力的东西
我不会跟你分析一大堆废话
你只要记得就是
1700上下
明天开盘
基本上就是开在
季线这个附近
1700的位置
明天的
明天的剧本非常有可能
开在这个位置之后
往下灌
到1700
万七就是
就是可能50啊這個地方
話太亂了
它可能開下去就差不多在17
好然後呢
然後呢
5分開
9點開這邊嘛
十分左右
十分左右开始
主意就开始可能散户啊等等
就往下灌
到50啊
或者是00这个位置
这个050
然后到万七这个位置
然后
你就要去观察一件事情了
同学记得哦
观察什么勒
非常简单
好
你看个股
看个股
一定是长这个样子
开这样嘛
对不对
然后往下
五分K往下灌之后
好
有没有出现一个什么
这种直接把它吞噬的
红K
你要去收入起来
懂意思吗
它开盘开下去之后
重点就是你的个股
你的个股
你要去看
因为毕竟我们赚钱就是赚这个嘛
赚个股的钱嘛
你要去知道
你要去收入哪一些标题
就是
急刹两根
5分K之后
有没有这种红K拉上来的
红K拉上来的
这个你尾盘就要来留意
所以这个是我
这个明天
9点到9点半
要去观察东西
我不会马上接
我一定是等到尾盘
我会把这些东西全部收录起来
然后尾盘的时候
发给这个群组里面
这是我今天收录到的一些标的
然后是有符合我长这个状况的
那我现在就把这个方法
就是分享给大家
你可以去观察看看
懂意思吗
这开盘是一定开
就是前一天已经是这样了
对不对
这样
然后同学记得
记得
明天啦
明天
为什么会画这样呢
很简单
抱歉
为什么画这样
非常简单
明天
強的股
開盤先跌2%
懂嗎
平均
平均大概就是3%左右
那弱的股
就是5%
懂嗎
這邊畫一下
來看一下
看一下
明天基本上就是先付2%
個股基本上
應該
然後平均大概就是3到4%左右正常的正常的那大碟比較弱勢的有势的就是5%懂意思吗基本上就是先开个2%
开个2%
OK
好
所以
记得
重点就是
你要把这个
这个情况
情况记下来
然后你尾盘的时候
就可以来去做
涨下好的
你就去做切入
这样子
我这地方
不会去看太空
你这个地方甚至
甚至给大家一个比较明确的
你还可以去偏小多
短多的一个行情
短多的行情
这是我自己的看法
毕竟多方的因子已经蛮多的了
什么叫多方因子
很简单
多方因子
颈线
颈线是一个多方因子
然后季线是一个多方因子
然后通道底就是布林的下轨
是一个多方的
的这个因子
通道底
明天会往上
懂意思吗
它不会是在这个
16995这个位置
它会往上延伸
可能就到
17050左右
看一下
你看一下嘛
前一天
来前一天
同学你看一下
前一天的通道底是多少
对不对
隔一天
变995
31编上95
那差不多加60点
那明天
你再往上加个五六十点
也差不多就是050
就是050
就是17050这个位置
所以明天我个人去规划
去看这个状况
可能开下去
也可能就在100上下
100之下这样子
然后主力再往下灌一下
主力再往下
开已经开了
你就假设啦
好我們就開17
17080好了
抓一個
好
往下灌一下
可能到這個
這個
的位置
馬上就碰到這個
上升的
通道底
可能就會出現一個
力道
就會出現一個力道
那我就會開始去
觀察
有沒有一些5分K是往下灌
往下灌之後
馬上一根
紅K
拉上來的
5分K已經開低了
開低之後再往下灌這樣子OK然後反轉陽吞式陽吞式這樣OK這種收入起來你尾盤看一下它能不能还是原本的这种延续延续这个气势
收一根
收一根什么
最后它的日K
要收一个什么
收一个这个样子
OK
这个应该很明确
这个规划应该非常明确了
来同学
讲到这个位置
刚刚是讲五分K
这是讲日K的涨像
讲到现在
第二段
第二段操作规划
盘式的解析操作规划
解析加操作规划
这个部分
你听得懂的
你就帮我打加2
好不好
这是我们第二part了
帮我打加2
这个毕松刚刚有问到
叶毕松同学
新奇节课盘
这个部分应该算是解得非常的
清楚明确而暴力了吧
就是简单明了
OK
好
这是
就是我们的一个规划
好
好了
再来再来
刚刚我们回顾的讲完了
然后未来的讲完
我们现在就开始讲
我们从
大方向
大方向讲完了
我们现在开始来讲个股了
讲个股了
第一个公开群
在公开群里面有讲到的
我们先来看一下
好
等一下
我们现在开始缩小部分
缩小部分
来
第一个有问到的是
2603的长荣
长荣
这个
来同学你还有海的吗
还有人有海的部分吗
嗨的
这个地方就是比较
真的是筹码比较乱
筹码比较乱
你看一下主力卖
外资卖
然后投信还是有买钞
在这个地方
那这个
在这个位置
我会去看
你这个月线
月线
明天开下去
可能就要月线
同学记得
我刚讲的部分
明天你强的股票
强的股票
你开两%
开低两%
懂吗
开低两%是正常
弱的就是5%以上
5%那就是很弱了5%真的很弱開2%我都覺得算強勢2%開2%那2%以上就不用更不用了
開1%
是不是開平盤沒事的
哇塞
那你絕對把它收入起來
懂的是嗎
或者是開紅的
開紅的
我也覺得你可以多看一下
但是你不要馬上進行切入懂嗎
因為你開盤
開紅色
你可能很容易被大家賣掉
懂嗎
就是
有紅的那我趕快也先丟一丟好了
但是你可以把它先收入起來
至少在大盤往下全部開下去的時候
它居然可以開個紅
那這個算是蠻了不起的
了不起的懂意思嗎
OK
好再來
來第一個是長榮
長榮開下去在月線
月線季線這個地方你可以得到一個支撐
它可能開在月線然後往下
碰到這個1122
112抱歉
這個位置其實12.9差不多啦
在這個位置你會得到一個支撐
你會得到一個支撐
基本上
這是屬於土羊對坐
這個投信在這邊買了非常多
這個框框
買非常多
所以
基本上
基本上我認為這個地方
月線還有季線
會有一個多方的支撐存在
存在
ok
啊对了
等一下
在讲
这个刚刚一开始没有
没有讲到警语的部分
就是
这些所有都是
无常无私的去做分享
就是
我不希望
就是会
之后会
因为这个
免费的东西
得到一些麻烦
所以
那个正义摩人
你可以先离开
没关系
如果我讲不对的话
那我可以
先跟你说声抱歉
讲不对
先跟你说抱歉
那同学们记得
投资必定有风险
然后你必须要了解这个
下单前你必须要了解这个判断
判断要真的要属于独立判断
要审慎评估好不好
OK
我们这边就是心得的分享
以过去新的经验去做分享
但是这个过去的这些经验
不能代表未来投资的依据
OK我觉得这个景欲要先讲一下
不然我觉得自己这个得物尝试很麻烦
我們今天就是想說可能大家在開盤
明天開盤前會很緊張的
我想說就來上面和大家一起哭
對不對 我們要笑的時候一起笑
他大赚钱一起笑嘛
那哭的话那就一起哭嘛
对不对
就是来找温暖的
找温暖的
OK
好
哇这个今天蛮难得的
结果还有300多人
蛮
对
好
所以
超级的结论就是
他在越线
越线去做防守
多方的支撑
OK
好
再来看到下一个是金豪科
我们先把这边讲完
我们再来帮大家去回答
及时的个股状况
这边
我现在照着这边念
到这边讲
讲解
全部都是在公开群里面
还有我们订阅群组的部分
OK
这个地方
这个下面是订阅群组
昨天有做过一次了
今天再做一次
怕大家可能有
我觉得有漏掉的部分
OK
好
金豪科
来看一下
明天开低下去
来
再上升的预线
它都会得到支撑的
所以你可以用我昨天
刚刚讲的
不是昨天
刚刚讲的部分
去做观察
懂吗
它开低下去
开低下去
在上升的月线之中
它都可以得到什么
得到一个支撑
上下去
有机会怎么样
往上拉一个
OK
好
再来
对啊同学没错
就是希望这个地方
不会让你觉得很有压力
因为我知道
其他地方都讲得非常厉害
非常浮夸
然后好像自己
操作永远不会亏损
然后永远每一笔都是正确
每一笔都是获利
然后完全不会
就是永远可以买低卖高
然後做的每一個測交易都是賺錢的
我知道有很多地方在造神
造神就是懂大家懂意思
但是沒有
這個地方你不會看到這種現象
我和大家都是一樣的
那我們就是都是在這個市場裡面去打滾
那我就分享一下我的看法
我的看法這樣子
我覺得這樣聽起來應該會比較舒服一點
比較舒服一點
然後也讓大家知道
其实我们是真的有在操作的
OK
好
再来看一下这个华航华航的部分其实这个短线上面有做到有做到但是其实重点来在这个位置非常明确的和大家讲到我们之前讲到
如果你上礼拜二
上礼拜四这些影音
你都有看到的话
你就会知道
我们要观察的重点在哪边
就是在这29块
我这也说的非常多次了
29块这一根
11月16号的高点29块
它过去的话
短线上面是有一个
这个获利空间的
但非常非常小
但是重点是什么
你要知道一件事情
就是他在开盘跌破29块的时候
要非常小心
非常小心
同学你有听到
主义大讲
华航关键在29块
关键价转强转弱点
关键价在29块的
你帮我打华航
帮我打29块就好
你帮我打29块
华航29好了
你就帮我打华航29
就是如果你觉得
这个你
这个之前有听到
就是
我讲这个部分
然后你有听进去的
你就帮我打华航29
就可以了
所以未来
怎么样看华航
非常简单
就是至少
他要把华航29
占回去
这个缺口
你一定要占回去
然后这个低点在多少
29.3
你一定要站回去
所以基本上同学
你可能追在这个地方
追在这个地方
你开盘你看到他跌破29块
他绝对有让你时间去跑
绝对有机会
为什么
因为他你看
他开完之后
还往上碰了一下28.9
他就是没办法碰到29块了
懂意思吗
因为开盘站就决定了主力的意图
清楚吗
开盘这样就决定主力的意图了
它居然可以开破29
那它就是要往下跌的一个命运了
懂意思啊
就跟
来我看一下
我们上次讲到的
等一下哦
看一下
等一下
这个做法跟这个一样
跟这个一样
你回顾一下星期四的时候
我们还要讲到一个部分
今日还可以多看台光电和广达
为什么会有这件事情
非常简单因为我在盘前的时候为什麼會讓請大家要留意台光電因為我在盤前的時候試戳的時候
發現你重點
它開過了
關鍵價251.5
這邊高點251.5
251.5
來這個地方畫一條線過去
這一檔是我們在昨天的時候
就是星期三的时候
有选到的股票
但是我觉得它的股性没有到很好
把它收入起来一下
收入起来
那收入到我自选里面
我就会观察一下
每个人试错
错了怎么样
对不对
我前一天请大家小心这一档
可能又像这个地方
开高走低
但是
这一天不一样的是什么
不一样是
它开盘的时候试错是252
然后开盘直接也是一样
就开252上去
那这一种
就像是我们刚刚讲的
开盘价决定主力意图
OK来你帮我刷一下
听懂我讲的
开盘价决定主力意图
你把它记一下
你自己记在脑里面
开盘价决定主力意图
这真的非常重要
真的非常重要同学
你要了解的重点就是什么
就是你要知道
它的关键价在哪边
它的多点触碰
确认关键价
这是一个一个一个脉络下来的
懂意思吧
这个部分我们在之前的直播
之前的教学已经有讲过很多次
这已经是第24期了
这直播已经是第24期
每一集的直播都是有一个多小时
你觉得我前面后面废话很多
没关系你去看中间
也有一个小时的精华
这个部分我们之前还用到很多档标的上面
很多档标的上面
OK
好
所以记得
我请你打这个
和我讲讲这个
开盘下决定主力图
这个是不是打给我看的
懂吗
这是打给你自己看的
打给你自己看的
就是你之后
你之后就绝对会有这个印象了
OK
好
那你说华航对不对
华航拉回来
拉回来
好
明天一样往下开到月线
它会有一个支撑
那如果你真的
真的转强的话
非常简单
你把這個缺口補起來
不然你就先不用理它
或者是你就是只能
就要看你自己要不要去做動作了
懂嗎不然你就要等一陣子你要把這29.3補回來你才可以再去做就是再做動作懂意思嗎好就是如果你要做多的話
他真的要轉到強勢
轉強的話
把這缺口補起來
否則他都會在這地方持續的震盪
震盪
OK
好再來
看下一個
我們盡量因為公開群組
公開群組是一個禮拜一次而已
一個禮拜一次的這個直播
然後投票
盡量把它講的詳細一點
因為不像我們訂閱群組
基本上是非常頻繁來做見證這樣子
OK
好 聯電
聯電
聯電這個地方我覺得也不用太過的緊張
為什麼
因為季線月線都在這個位置
他明天開下去之後這個地方
高機率
高機率會有多方的力道存在
為什麼 因為他佔全值股
明天我們說往下開往下殺之後
你要在大盤往上做一個V轉的話
他其實也不會缺席
大概是這樣 好嗎
看一下這邊上升月線
跌破下去之後
其實這個地方你都還可以去
去留意一下他是不是真的
就出現什麼
出現這種紅梯出來
了解我意思嗎
但說實在他的籌碼真的不太好
真的不太好
就是
主力賣外資賣投信賣
他真的要轉強
真的要真的
我想要切入的時候
大概是
他要至少站到這個位置以上
這個地方
就是66以上
收盤站上66塊
OK
好這邊有個缺口
大家看得出來這邊有個缺口
然後上次完全站不上去
OK
好
話說那邊
其實我們還有做一趟系統
2363系統
整個一根10%
當天一根10%
好
來
創尾
明天碰月線
主力買外資買頭
這個
我覺得
明天開下去
你都還可以去留意
懂意思嗎
這明天開下去
都還可以去留意
為什麼
因為它籌碼是不錯的
你看一下
對這個買進來的
它這個是
就是有他們的存在
外資的存在
外資星期五還放假
然後他們還來買這張標的
不然它其實
已经跌得稀巴烂了
懂意思吗
但是明天又有个机会往月线开
你就可以去留意一下
它是不是就是我出现的状况
所以这个我反而会乐观看待
创围
好吧
好
黄邦店也是
二三三
二三四四
下一档是黄邦店
黄邦店这个灌破下来
到这个月线
相信我
它
不要说相信我
抱歉抱歉
不行不行
相信我
应该说高几率
它是会有一个多方的
支撑存在的
为什么
他筹码是好的
主力买外资买
投信买
懂意思吗
所以你要去看这种
筹码好的标题
他会比较容易
明天出现买盘
懂吗
那我刚刚
我刚刚已经有
列了
应该是我昨天
已经有列了一些
列了一些
然后明天还会在
应该说稍后
稍后稍晚之后
还会再列那个
明天要观察的
筹码好的标的出来
给订阅的同学们
OK
好 铃声一样做盘整
这个地方把这个切掉
你只要这样看就好了
稍等我一下
来 这样子
有铃声同学你就这样子
跟我做同样一件事情
把这两点
这个
切好
明天就到这个位置附近
等一下我的花束
明天到这个附近的时候
你就可以留意一下
就是25这附近
上次一次两次
可能打第三次
还有机会
懂意思吗
在做封测的
但是主力持续在做卖潮
然后外资也持续在做卖潮
所以你这地方就要考量一下
你到底要不要等这么久
但是短期支撑是这样子
了解意思吗
OK
好
好光磊
光磊其实这个筹码是不差的
你看这边
这几个都还要在买超
明天开下去
可能就到这一个附近
好51
應該沒有到51這麼誇張這太多了可能一兩兩三趴能就是在53这个位置附近那其实上一次到十字线
是它的起涨点
这个地方
十字线你就可以寻求一个支撑
在这个位置
观察一下
我觉得它的筹码没有到太差
所以一样去看一下
是不是有我讲的那一个状况存在
往下杀之后
急啦
你看这地方
上次十字线没有站稳
实现没有站稳
站稳之后
一天两天就拉出去
所以这个地方可以留意一下
又到它的惯性的
多方均线上面了
OK
好来我们看下一个
2498宏达电
来宏达电
他们这个元宇宙概念
我像宏达电啊
玉创啊
然后威胜啊
明天都有非常机会
像我讲的刚刚那个状况
注意就是急杀下去之后
反而V转上去
因为为什么
因为他们就是腰骨
你不能用常态去判断他们
所以明天到这个位置之后
他很快的就会来到什么
这个上升的
抱歉吧
等一下换一个
上升的下跪
所以这个地方它是
以这个布林的操作方式来看
这个地方会出现多方的力道
会出现多方的力道
看这个地方是
昨天是63.6
今天加两块
明天可能就到67这附近
其实在这个70的位置
可以有一个多方的力道存在
所以里面留意一下
它开下去之后
有没有机会再往上拉抬
这个其实它到这个下轨
是有这个多方的力道的
毕竟这个法则没有问题
就是上轨到下轨的话
一次到下轨的话
它其实这个下轨会有多方的支撑存在
了解一下
就是这个一个法则
一个法则
但是因为我不知道你的
你的持股的部位
还有成本在哪边
懂我意思嗎
就是應該還是有不少同學
有宏達電啊玉創啊衛生這些長相都是一樣的長相都是一样的所以记得开下去之后你要留意一下它有没有一个V转上来
但是记得这种长相的
V转上来的时候
你就要去思考一件事情
是不是要去该做减码的
懂吗 该做减码
因为毕竟怎么样
这个地方大量都在这上面
这个大量
我画一下
画过来
这样子
好 你看一下下面
量最大的时候就是在
上面都已经被跌破了
被跌破了
OK 所以
他明天的
这个位置
86块
86块附近
就会是他的很大的压力了
懂我意思吗
这元宇宙概念的过程就要休息一下
稍微休息一下
盘整
盘整休息一下
好吗
好 再来
尾全垫
来 这个尾全垫你看一下
这个地方
从上轨
来 注意听
注意听 同学
从上轨然后一路这样子
跌破
往下跌破
这个在明天的时候都会有出现多方的
几率
都有这个几率
了解意思吗
这就很明确
就像是我刚刚讲的
就是很容易这样开下去之后
开下去之后
然后往下刹
然后再出现这种反转的可能
为什么
因为它的这个形态
它的形态
是属于多方的因子会比较多的
了解意思吗
你看一下嘛
看一下
这个地方
前高的位置
加上這個地方還有一個缺口
缺口在這邊
然後布林再畫下來
在中間
所以這個地方的多方音質是非常多的
了解一下
這樣畫應該看得懂
應該看得懂
所以在這個地方
在93塊
93塊附近
這個地方都可以去留意一下
留意一下
這一檔好不好
好 我们先来到下一个
好 订阅群组的部分好 第一个是新唐新唐这蛮强的新唐这蛮强的好这很逆势的收红
好
逆势收红
所以
这种逆势收红的
来
主力买
外资买
投信买
哎
明天
明天开盘的时候
开盘的时候
好
你开下去
你就可以去留意一下
这种
有没有做
这个力道的买盘
懂意思吗
因为它筹码是好的
所以
今天的重点非常明确
就是
你要去知道
哪一些筹码是好的
这种明天
有反转的机会是非常大的
清楚我意思吗
OK
好
华航刚讲过了
看一下
来看一下
有蛮多重复的
大家可以看一下
华航重复了
然后长荣
那我们看一下
星星
这边讲星星
伟权店重复
金星
元太
好
连店重复
OK
好我们来看一下
下一个是303
星星是3037
这个OK
好这也是非常强势的
好你看一下
大盘现在的状况
跟他现在状况来
你看一下同学
星星这样子
是强还是弱
你用均线来看
他是强还是弱势
来回答一下
回答一下
他是強還是弱
對沒錯沒錯沒錯
他這裡算非常強勢
為什麼勒很簡單
我們來看一下
用一個方式
就可以知道
他是強勢還是弱勢了
就看他和大盤的
對比就可以了
你就看他
他这个大盘对比就可以了
大盘是全部
大盘在这个位置
大盘是破十日五日还有月线
星星是还站在所有均线之上
懂意思吗
所以这种股票
你明天反而就可以留意一下
它是比大盘还强势的股票
懂意思吗
中哥说明天就变弱了
但是相信我
他也是弱
弱里面最强的
懂意思吗
相信我
他也是明天弱
一片弱里面最强的
OK
好
这就是为什么你要去选择
去看比大盘还强势的股票
因为这个大盘弱势的时候
原本股票很
在大盘强势的状况下面
如果一档股票已经很弱了
当大盘转弱的时候
这些股票只会更弱而已
就这样
懂意思吗
好那我刚刚讲的
你们去观察一下
是不是我讲的这样
懂吗
明天一定是全部都是弱的
全部都是弱的
OK
好
那就是要去留意一下
留意一下
哪一些在全部股票里面
都是弱势的情况下
它是有挺身而出的
挺身而出的
这个是我明天要做的
非常重要的一个功课
一个功课
OK
好
所以明天
这其实你也不用太过的
如果你问了同学
我看有53位同学问这一档
那其实你也不用太过担心
我们刚刚有讲到的部分
你用这一根
你应该说不用用这一根
你直接用月线做防守就可以了
你看一下
这边月线防守
然后我们之前有讲到一个部分
对不对
就是这个
星星她的长约
她的长约已经是在
已经签到
2023年的
对不对
好
我们看一下下一档
下一档
下一个是243
我先讲过了
好 強茂 好 強茂 OK
好 來 這邊 好好来这边来
强茂这个地方
你看一下
投信都已经这个要买超了
对买超
买超在这个位置
然后在他
星期五的情况
他有量缩的稍微下跌了一点点
稍微下跌一点点
那你们去留意一下
它的季线这个地方
能不能寻求到一个支撑
上次在这个季线盘整了一下
然后拉出去
盘整了一下拉出去
OK
这一次你就要去观察
它的季线
是不是有守住的
懂是吗
看一下哦
看一下
这边跌破季线
然后往下
往下侧
这边站上季线往上走
回到季线
又再往上拉一次
所以明天去留意一下
这100块附近
有没有做支撑
这是我们一定要去观察的东西
OK
好
再来
8183金星
好
正简单
就守住五日线就可以了
好不好
明天守住五日线就可以了
OK
好
因为这个
其实这个上影线算有点长
有点长
而且还是出量的
出量上影线
然后
这应该是获利的麦亚
這邊三年內都沒有前高了
對不對
OK
好
再來最後一個是8069元泰
元泰
好
看一下
這地方它出量的
出量的跌破五日線
但是你要去留一件事情
這個位置
這個位置會是有一個非常強力的支撐存在
在十日線位置
它的缺口
这个低点
把它画一下
这个红线以下
是一个多方缺口
对不对
然后到这个地方
是非常重要要观察的
绝对不能跌破
了解的意思吗
基本上你不会买在这个位置
你一定是买在这个下面
但是你现在就要思考的是
要去如何去做挺立的
对不对
这个地方有一个非常重要
要去观察的
懂吗
明天的十日线111
加上这个
這個低點 你看一下 也是110.5所以明天你可以直接去防守111防守111就可以了 不能跌破這個低點110.5所以明天你可以直接去防守防守111防守111就可以了不能跌破这个低点110.5了解意思吗
OK
好
这边基本上都有去做
做回答了
人音中大概是15档左右
15档左右
这地方你听得懂的话
你就帮我打加3
听得懂加3
应该有回答到
应该都有回答到了
对不对
OK
好
那应该是没有什么太大问题
来同学
我们先来开放
如果你有
刚刚那些的个股
没有回答到你的个股的话
你可以在这边
就是提出来
提出来
我们做及时的
及时的帮你做QA
好不好
就分享一下我的看法而已
因为可能
大家的
操作方式
然后操作经验
然后部位成本都不同
那就希望可以帮助到你
好帮助到你
好我看到了
来这个Gmail问道623的
旺9
我记得它是一个
蛮腰的IC设计
来这种长相
这种长相
相信我它就是我们刚刚讲的
就是大盘强势的时候
来
这一段大盘强势的时候
它没有动
大盘弱势的话
这种你就要真的非常小心了
非常小心了
了解我意思吧
它就可能
这个瀑布就直接开始成立了
成立了
所以记得
记得
拜托
它有往上拉收红的时候
它都会是你要去做动作的机会
越线超级大压力
越线是个标准大的压力
OK
好
好今天幫大家回答來這個也是一樣已經星期五就已经跌破季限他明天可能就直接往下往下
那这个地方都要小心
所以记得
同学
我会说往下的原因
就是因为这个盘面
盘面状况
你看星期五晚上的夜盘的状况
你就会知道有一个心理准备了
懂吗
这种往下之后
他会出现一个跳空缺口
那星期五的收盤价
就会是它一个超级大的压力
这种跌破下去之后
均线就会往下开始做瀑布
空方的瀑布就出来了
懂吗
所以
这要小心一点
请你要去做一些动作
如果它真的有V转上来收红的话
要小心一点
好不好
好 再来下一个
3169的亚信
亚信明天开下去
这个地方我觉得
亚信其实在这一波上来
真的算是非常强势的
他算是比大盘强非常多的
强非常多的
他这个这波上来
其实也赚了
应该有同学
我不是说我
应该说也有同学
也这地方也赚了
蛮大一段的
我好像看到有同学的
对上单
有亚信这一档
所以明天
开下去
守住这个十字线就好
守住這十線就沒事
了解為止嗎
OK
好 我們繼續
我們繼續
來看一下
還有2342
好
這個2342
它算是
星期五的時候
算是表現得還不錯
那你
很簡單
你用這個月線去做防守
它多方還是進行當中
你看長一點
看長遠一點
你把月線守住就可以了
好 月線
有沒有
月線
守住月线往上攻击
回测一下再往上攻击
他盘是好的时候
他其实有变成什么
时日线了
但很可惜
他这个大盘突然遇到一些状况
那我们就回测
向下找直沉
了解意思吗
下一个是
这个眩民问道的美琪
这个部分也是要小心
你看一下
看一下
来
同学看一下
这个是上升的月线
但它的月线已经怎么样
已经走平了
这个月线已经走平了
而且明天开下去的话
破
這個布林 壓縮後的布林
同學
這你就要稍微的留意一下
是不是馬上要去做處理了
清楚嗎
假設
我假設哦
我假設可不可以
假設
明天開下去到這個位置
他的布林就打開了
就開布林了
好就開布林了
所以這個
明天開盤的時候
拜託你可能就要
緊急的
盯一下
好不好
這個宣明同學
OK
好再來余軒問到2069
我們現在都要去假設一件事情
就是明天是開下去是一個很
一個缺口出來
它會到哪裡
了解我意思嗎
好
來
這個明天開下去
就是在月線
所以月線這個地方都會有出現支撐
好
所以這個就可以
可以再多等一下
要多等一下
懂嗎
OK
運倉是這樣
好不好
上升嘛
然後回測
到月線
應該啦
應該這地方都會出現
多方的力道存在
好上升月線
OK
你到底假設一下
明天會開到哪邊
好
這個長榮行的話
跟這個黃是一樣的道理
好明天開破月線
他都有機會出現
這個力道
好多方力道
OK
但是要真正轉強
你要真正轉強
你至少要把這個
看一下
這個高點
29.35
29.35站上
再来看
29.35站上再来看
这边存在了太多的
套牢的卖压了
我不喜欢就是我的个股左边有很多的卖压
好
加零做光学的
光学车用镜头的光学
明天开下去也是到月线
然后这地方还有一个缺口在这个地方
这个地方
所以月线基本上会有人做防守
有人做防守
你基本上就守月線就可以了
守住月線
好不好
好
你聽懂了
你就稍微跟我講一下
有解到你的歌
你就幫我講一下
來
這個地方也一樣
到月線守住
最後還是月線守住
基本上都是這種答案
你想像一下
往下開一個缺口出來
到月線
都是有多方的力道
好
再來
哦
這個
來
你這種就要小心了這種就要小心了懂吗这种就開盤可能就要馬上處理了開盤可能就要馬上處理
為什麼
你看他的均線已經是往下的瀑布了
要貫穿這個季線了
假設
我假設行不行
假設他明天開這個地方
均線全部就會跟過來了
了解意思嗎
所以反弹上来
记得你都要去做动作
拜托
季线位置非常的
压力非常大
56块压力超级大
压力超级大就是你的卖压了
不是卖点是卖压
好卖压OK
好
2338光照
这个张同学
张同学问到光照
光照这边算是强势的
算是强势的
他至少星期五
还有一个网上攻击的想法
一个想法
好
明天开破月线
上升月线
他都会有多方的力道存在
你可以去观察一下
观察一下
这个没有到像刚刚那些这么紧急
这么紧急
毕竟他这个是第一次跌破月线
他都会有出现反弹的力道
了解我意思吗
好
这个伯汉问到安国
安国来明天也是
这其实
星球的状况
它本来蛮强势的
结果
变到弱势了
为什么
它后来杀下去了
但是
前面
这个地方有个缺口存在
然后刚好在哪边
刚好在这个月线的位置
明天也是一样
会有这个多方的地道存在
你看看这个缺口
这缺口
缺口存在在这个地方
所以
你可以观察一下
观察一下
但是比較小心的一件事情就是
它這樣往下跌的話
這個大量的低點就被跌破了
就比較
壓力就比較大一點
這兩根
兩根超級大壓力
這一根還有這一根
那你就守住月線
好不好
守住月線
OK
好
我看一下我們剛剛回答了哪一些同學
12345678910
同学11位了
11位了OK来我们要分享一下QA到这个地方结束因为我们后面还有这个要分享给大家的策略选股清单
就是筹码的部分
我们刚刚不是讲到一个部分
就是说
那个如果你是要去观察
有个短多的机会
短多的机会
对不对
你要去找那种筹码是好的
线形是好的
个股
对吧
所以等一下就帮大家去做分享
这个选股的清单
选股的清单
分享给大家
那
如果你有
这个
没有问到的问题的话
问到的问题的话
没关系
你可以
搜索这个
先扫这个QR Code
等一下
你可以进到这里面去问
这边
给大家一点时间
我喝一口水
好不好
同学这边
记得
如果你是有订阅的同学
你不用紧张
在这边不用急着和别人抢着来问
没关系
你就把问题等一下下播之后
直播结束之后
直接贴到
贴到你有我的私讯
或者是在讨论群里面发问
我都会直接先优先来去做处理
那如果你不是订阅同学
也没有关系
你直接扫这个QR Code
我把它放大一点
你就会进到我们公开的群租里面
来和所有股市里面的同学去做讨论
那如果你有问题丢出来
我把订阅同学的问题都处理好了之后
我就来稍微这边看一下
看一下了解为实吗
好
来
来我喝一口水
同学你可以把这个连结
我们现在直播这连结
分享给你觉得需要的同学
需要的朋友
都是跟他说这是免费的教学
我们今天已经开到第24集了
24期了
你去头去尾
觉得我讲话很多废话
你就把中间的节度下来
其实每集也一个小时
OK
好
好看看
好好来看一下手碼來
來這是給大家的
來注意到這邊這邊
哈囉哈囉
來這是第一個部分
好這第一個部分
來同學歡迎你截圖
歡迎你截圖
你就拿去用
拿去用沒關係好不好
等一下
剛剛的PPT在哪邊
看一下
好
這邊
稍等我一下
來
我幫大家
用一個比較
好
等我一下
马上
这是投信的嘛
对不对
好
稍等我一下
等一下我給大家比較好結的版本
好這個是
等一下喔
這樣上一個
好這樣子
另外一個因為我這個今天沒有把它做出來
沒有做PPT啦
這是外資的
等一下喔
稍等我一下
我看一下
看我这个地方有没有漏掉
成交量大一點好了
稍等我調一下參數
好
好完成
不会很多吧
对不对
来
这样
一个是投信的
一个是外资的
这样好吧
我把他用小一点
好同学可以
把它存起来
解读起来
不要让他盖到
OK
好
这样子
好不好
这样看清楚吗
同学看得清楚吗
同学们看得清楚吗
看得清楚吗
应该不会很多啦
对不对
这一页
同學們有看到了嗎
我要確認一下大家還在這樣
OKOK好有就好了
有就好了
OK
好對這樣子
讓大家自己去做功課
好不好
那你有訂閱同學
沒關係
你觉得很复杂很麻烦
没关系
你就等一下
等我晚一点晚一点会把它精选出来贴到我们等一下的寫到我們今天的選股文章裡面去
OK
好OK
那應該都解好了吧
都解好了
那你等下下播之後
你就可以去做功課了
這邊真的非常少啊
非常少
24681012141618
20檔
20檔這樣全部看完
大概就是20分鐘
就20分鐘而已
真的
同學
如果你是1700多檔
現在1750檔了
最後你的策略篩出來
你只剩下20檔來看
那個真的是
算是很精選的
然後你20檔裡面
再挑3檔出來
就是你覺得
依照你自己
過去的這種操作經驗
判斷
他應該是明天開下去
然後直接會有
有一個神奇的V轉上去的
你就剩下去
大概就3檔左右
那这部分如果你觉得
这个20档还太多了
没关系
我等一下会
这个写到文章里面
可能就是几档而已
几档而已
OK
好
大家清楚了就好了
OK
好再来
好最后一个部分啦
最后一个部分
就是和大家报告一下
好
这是我们刚刚有几件事情
要和大家讲的
昨天有一些录音
有一些设备的
让大家听起来觉得很
很阿扎
很不好意思
就是有点问题
录音设备有点问题
但现在已经排除了
你看我现在讲的这个就是
这个
没问题的了
就是没问题的了
OK
好
再来第二件事情
主力大又受邀这个
丑马K线
达人选股竞赛
下周开始
非常刺激
真的非常刺激
在这个崩盘的时候
这个情绪非常恐慌的时候
开始做这个达人选股的竞赛
大家应该知道
同学上一次的选股竞赛
是六月底的事情
那时候我们选了哪些股票
大家有印象吗
我把它回顾了一下
六月底的时候
选了一档
选了十档标的
因为连续两个礼拜
但这个礼拜只有
这个精彩只维持一个这一次只有一次上次是兩次上次是選什麼上次我記得選新唐在哪邊在這邊
在這邊
再來是選什麼
光照
在那邊
光照後來有疊下去
在這邊
我們都非常清楚
6月20號那一週
然後還有
6月29號那一週
所以持續的兩個禮拜
持續兩個禮拜
這結果都沒有給我表現
還有6485點序
點序
在哪邊
在這邊
還有哪一檔
被大家
詬病的
被大家詬病的
經驗
在哪邊
選在哪邊我看一下
6月15日6月20號
在這邊
6月20號
還有哪一個
華晴
6月15號這邊
這邊
還有漢磊
這些我選過的股票我都記得
上次參加比賽是這樣
15號18號這一週
在這邊
这次一样
就加油
下次应该说这次就是我们
只有一周
看一下
看一下是这边
达人选股竞赛
下周开始
然后要拿三档
三档拿出去比赛
上次是五档
这次是三档
然后筹K的时候
在周一的晚上九点
就是明天晚上九点会公布
但是我今天
就会先写在
我们PP的文章里面
我要拿出去比赛的三档股票
然后我们这订阅的
一定是优先的嘛
对不对
好再来
我明天中午我要打第二季的BNT
晚上不一定有朋友圈的教学影音
但是我会看身体的状况
那大家知道我个性会尽量的完成
好那第四点
非常多同学有在问实战和牛
什么时候可以报名
什么时候有多的名额
好这边
这个实战和牛
意思都是受完的情况
那和大家去争取这个部分我们是在下周三的晚上12点会有这个部分市出名额以上就是今天这几点
除了股派以外的事项
和大家做报告还有预告
看一下
那一样最后的PPT拿出来
直播的特别的福利
一样每次直播
最后都会开放20位
加入我们实战牛肉的
名额
那和牛的部分
你可以先不用考虑
和牛的是你要
在实战牛肉已经完全的了解
主流在讲的内容
你才有办法去
这个操作的和牛部分
实战和牛
那新手同学
我希望大家的入手
非常的廉价
低价的
那就是用这个899的方式
让你可以去学到哪一些东西
就是每天的当冲
短线还有筹码观察股
就像我们等一下要写的这个波段的筹码股
你可以来看一下
三档拿出去比赛的
再来这个每周246会有三部的盘后引擎教学
我们昨天才有丢出这个教学
每周246都会有
再来主力大波段的持股追踪还有分享
我进哪一些卖哪一些你一定都会知道
你在盘中也会知道
OK
尾盘我会说
我在看哪一些标的
你就知道
其实我会
操作那些标的了
OK
再来
最后就是LINE的群组
千人禁言社群
我们两千位同学的
就是你刚刚看到的
这个大社群
是禁言的
盘中会丢
非常多的讯息
像是这个
今日可以多看台光店
台光店开过关键价
我们就知道
他就是要去涨停的
然后哪一些事件
你可以去留意这样子
提醒最重要其实
都是提醒各位一些状况
好
再来讨论群组
有近年的
当然也会让你讨论的
我在每一个
目前已经开了六个
教学的讨论群组
我都在里面
盘中会和大家一起讨论
当然还有
吉巴尔同学一起
做分享
再来
第三个就是
专属一对一的
就是如果你觉得
有些个股问题
你不好在
讨论群组里面问的话
没问题
你就在
你就会拿到我的私讯的连结
你就从这里面开始去问
OK
好
大概是这个样子
那就看大家
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕